so the 2020 game awards came and went
without any
sign of hogwarts legacy psy
why wasn't it at the game awards and
what does this mean for the game if
anything
should we be concerned and when will we
get a new update for hogwarts legacy
we'll talk about all of that and more in
today's video and we're starting
right now people of the internet retro
wrecking tour here if we're meeting for
the first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream
over on twitch if you're new to the
channel and want to keep up with all the
hogwarts legacy news theories and
speculation be sure you hit that
subscribe button and ring the
notification bell to make sure you don't
miss any new videos
even if wb won't give us new things to
talk about we're harry potter fans come
on we had years of experience at this
between book and movie releases
so trust me when i say we still have
plenty of items to discuss
here on the channel i have quite a few
hogwarts legacy videos in the works even
without new updates take that wb
now guys and gals i gotta be honest with
you i had hoped today i'd be releasing a
trailer reaction video instead of a
video like this but here we are just
about three months since the official
unveil of hogwarts legacy and
still no new information as much as i'm
anxious to know more just like many of
you i certainly don't think this is any
cause for concern
there were plenty of big 2021 games that
weren't at the game awards
nothing from god of war horizon no elden
ring plenty of 2021 titles we already
know about
didn't show up it's possible more and
more publishers are opting to give news
and updates to their games
on their own time when they can have
time to shine away from the other big
gaming news
i mean let's be honest if any of those
games i just mentioned dropped a trailer
next week they'd instantly be one of the
biggest stories in gaming
seeing the reaction and support of the
first trailer probably has wb
realizing the same with hogwarts legacy
we are starting to get into the middle
part of december and we're
inching closer to the time when numerous
companies start to close down for a
significant amount of time over the
holidays
for that reason i do think it is
starting to look
pretty unlikely we get any major new
information for hogwarts legacy
this year there was that little flurry
of activity on the official twitter
account near the end of november and
then it just
stopped out of nowhere even then though
that was largely just repeating
information that we
already knew from that trailer i also
have to admit i think it's looking more
and more likely that this will not
be an early 2021 release the game has
been in development for quite some time
but i don't think any of us want
avalanche to rush this
they should absolutely take their time
and make the best game
possible that's what we want avalanche
more than anything to me
it's always felt like a holiday 2021
game that's
more just a gut feel than anything i'm
not really sure why i think that
plenty of others have thrown out the
idea to release the game on september
1st which would of course
match the harry potter series for the
start of term at hogwarts
love the idea but the amount of planning
it would take to hit
that exact date i think makes it pretty
unlikely
not to mention september 1st is a
wednesday which isn't a typical release
day for video games
and publishers just don't really think
that way to be honest
the people actually working on the game
i could see them thinking this would be
a great idea but the publishers probably
would be like okay whatever
again not saying it's out of the
question but i do think it's unlikely
so what about news though when will we
get new news on hogwarts legacy
the game awards is certainly the last
big gaming event of 2020 which has left
most fans
already looking to next year's e3 as the
most likely time we'll see something new
when it comes to e3 i think it's safe to
say hogwarts legacy will almost
certainly have a presence there
but what will e3 even look like in 2021
the show was already suffering even
before the coven 19 pandemic which
ultimately led to the cancellation of e3
2020 but these are likely conversations
that are ongoing right now among the
industry
according to gameindustry.biz a quote
reimagined
close quote e3 will take place from june
15th
through june 17th 2021 but in a time
when virtual events are becoming more
and more commonplace there's no reason
wb needs to wait until e3 to release new
hogwarts legacy updates
and i should point out this is 100 me
speculating no
insider info whatsoever here i could be
totally wrong on all this
but i am curious to see what you guys
think will we have to wait all the way
until june before we get
any kind of significant update on the
game gosh i certainly hope not
keep in mind though most of us had to
wait for almost two
years from the time of the initial leaks
until the official reveal back in
september
so at the very least i mean at least we
won't be waiting two more years until we
get info for the game
right right it really just depends on
how wb chooses to handle the marketing
they could release gradual bits of
information each week for the next
several months and lead up to a big
reveal at e3
if their current social media posts are
any indication though they're instead
opting for a very slow burn with new
information
we can also take a look at another wb
game with gotham knights which has been
in a similar spot as hogwarts legacy
gotham knights was revealed back in
august and is also a game currently set
for 2021
but guess what there's been very little
additional information on that one as
well
one other angle to consider here it's
entirely possible that wb had been
planning some cross-promotion between
hogwarts legacy
and the upcoming fantastic beasts movie
which was originally scheduled to
release in
2021 but has now been bumped to 2022
for reasons we won't get into here so
this could have thrown a wrench into
their ultimate marketing plans for the
game and now they're needing to adjust
from everything we've seen so far though
i don't think there's any reason for us
to be concerned or worried about the
game's development
it just seems like we'll have to keep
waiting for new information and you know
exactly where you can find that new
information right here we'll make sure
to bring new videos to you
anytime if it's even a tweet a new
screenshot
we'll make sure to do a new video as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon